- One of the parts of growing up
is to getting your finances right.
It's about taking control
of your own money,
of your own financial situations,
and making the right and
responsible decisions
for your life.
Of course, this is easier said than done.
Some of us have the
benefit to have the luxury
of coming from maybe parents
who taught us some of
these important principles
are those don't and those
need to learn these things
by themselves over
their 20s and their 30s.
In this video, I wanted to share
some of the key principles,
some of the key thoughts
and considerations
that I personally picked up
during the course of my 20s,
and that for me, at least,
that is significant difference in my life,
and for my personal financial situation.
One thing I wanna say in the
beginning is that these things,
these ideas that I will not
present were not invented by me.
So these are things that
I picked up over time
by reading books, also
watching other YouTube videos.
This is just the best off of these ideas
that I really made this for myself,
and I hope that this will
be helpful for you as well.
So now without further
ado, let's get into it.
So when it comes to another coffee break,
here on my channel Firm
Learning, my name is Heinrich,
and as you know, on my
channel, I want to help you
to be become successful in the
first years of your career.
And for sure, getting your money right,
is a key part of that.
So this is what we're
going to talk about today.
And specifically I will
share five key lessons
that I picked up over time,
where I hope that these will
be helpful for you as well.
The first principle that
I think is a very crucial
is the principle of paying yourself first.
Because what do most people do wrong?
When most people get their paycheck,
there's already lots of taxes
deducted from the paycheck,
and then people spend the money
during the course of the month,
and then they think to themselves,
well, maybe at the end of the
month, if something is left,
I will save it.
I will invest it.
I will take it aside.
And then of course, no surplus
at the end of the month,
there often isn't much money left,
and then no, only very little
money is getting saved.
And the idea of paying yourself
first is the following.
So if you make a gross salary of 100%,
you're often in many countries,
depending of course, on the
exact income that you make,
and based on our tax system,
easily 40% of that salary
will be deducted by the state.
You will need to pay in
taxes and so on and so forth.
And clearly this would be the
deducted from your paycheck
in the very beginning.
So this doesn't depend
on how much money you
have left or whatever.
This is what will go out of your paycheck
from the very start.
And then the logic is, well, if the IRS,
if the financial authorities
are taking this money away from you,
shouldn't you then make
sure that you pay yourself
that very same amount of money as well?
Shouldn't you make sure
that then roughly 40%
of your gross salary is taken aside,
is saved, is invested as well?
This at least makes a lot of sense to me.
And if you assume that 40%
of the gross salary is taxes,
then 60% are your net salary.
This would then mean that
one third of your net salary
is really only what you
have available for living,
which would correspond to a
savings rate of about 66%.
This is of course quite significant.
And I once made a video that
I will link some above here,
where I talked about having
a savings rate of 50%.
And of course, it's also
clear that the more you earn,
the more privileged you
are with your salary,
the easier it will be for you
to save a substantial portion of that.
But at least as an aspiration,
as a goal that you aspire
towards, having that in mind
that you should probably pay yourself,
invest at least as much money
as the state takes away from you.
Related to that is the idea of not waiting
until the end of the month.
Until you take the money aside,
and then put it in your savings account
or into your investments.
But instead, make sure that you
take all this money directly
after your salary hits your bank account.
And you can do this in
different ways, for instance,
with a regular savings plan
that automatically then deducts the money
and puts it into the savings account,
or with an automated stock investment plan
where it can do all that.
But don't make it dependent
on your discipline,
but rather make sure that you invest it,
and then figure out how
to live on the rest.
At least assuming that
you're privileged enough
that this is (indistinct)
possible for you.
The second idea that
I wanna share with you
that I've found insanely valuable
is the idea of never touch principal.
So this is coming from finance,
where you distinguish
between the principal.
So the capital invested, for instance,
the capital invested into a
bond, and then the interest.
The interest that this capital pays.
And the key idea is that over time
you will build your capital.
You will build your
principal if you follow
especially also advice number one.
Every month, you will put money aside,
invest it for instance,
into the stock market.
This is the principal that
you will accrue over time,
and the principal that for
you will grow over time.
And the key point here is
that you should make sure
that you organize your life
in a way that you should
really make it a rule
that you do not take money out of that.
Never ever take money out
of this principal account.
Where you collect money, where
your capital is building.
Instead, you should
aspire to the situation
that maybe at some point in the future,
you live just by the interest.
So if your stocks pay dividends,
if your investments pay any
other type of interest, yes,
this is the money that
will available to you.
This is the money that
potentially at some point
you might also be able to spend,
but I would encourage you to especially
in the beginning rather reinvest it.
But at some point,
if you really make this a habit of yours,
of saving the money,
of investing the money,
if you're lucky enough,
if this plays out well,
at some point in your life,
you will be in a situation
where maybe all of your regular expenses,
all of your daily expenses,
you will be able just to
pay out of the interest
of the capital that you have invested.
This is also a variation of this idea
of passive income, right?
That you create income,
which does not need to be earned anymore.
That you're not dependent
anymore on your labor income,
but that you just can earn
income out of your principal.
The third point I want
to share with you today
is that you should really
absolutely track your net worth.
There's one famous saying in consulting,
probably not only consulting,
but rather general management wisdom,
which is you cannot manage
what you do not measure.
So if you do not measure your
net worth on a regular basis,
chances are higher that
you will really struggle
to manage that in the
way that it will regrow
to make sure that your
principal is growing over time.
And here, I also made a video in the past
where I talked about
how you can really track
this net worth, what the
net worth actually is,
how it is defined,
and even shared with you
a basic Excel spreadsheet,
where you really can do all this.
I will link it somewhere above here.
It's really the same tool,
the same Excel spreadsheet
that I use myself.
So hope that this is detailed for, to you.
And as you can just check out this video,
I will not repeat myself, but
just really wanna emphasize.
So from my perspective,
this is just crucial for you
accumulating wealth over time.
My insight number four
is that you just cannot start too early.
And this is probably a
mistake that also I myself did
because in my early
20s, what I thought was,
now I still don't earn that much money.
I was still at university at the time.
Why should I now really
restrict my lifestyle
if I don't have that much money, anyway?
What is really the value of saving
one or 200 Euro every month
if this really restricts my
lifestyle in a significant way?
And then probably later down the road,
it will be much easier for me
to save much more
significant amounts of money,
if I'm then like fully
arrived into the job market,
and then hopefully earn
some decent salaries.
This is what I was thinking at the time,
and I believe that this is
what many people are thinking.
What these people, and also I, myself
severely underestimated
at that point in time
is the power of compound interest.
There are a lot of crazy,
really super counterintuitive,
mind blowing calculation examples.
If you do some research on this
topic of compound interest,
but the bottom line
is that it makes a significant difference.
Whether you start investing in your 20s
compared to starting
investing in your 30s,
even though you just might start
with rather small amounts
of sums in your 20s.
You will very likely
significantly underestimate
the additional amount of money
that you will need to save
in your 30s, if you want to compensate
the money that you did
not save in your 20s,
even though these amounts
might've been only small amounts.
Again, these calculation
examples are really eye opening.
I included one of them in this video
where I talked about the 50% savings rate.
I very much encourage
you to check this out
if you haven't seen it yet.
My big recommendation to you
really is start investing
as early as possible, maybe
already in your high school,
just to get used of it.
For sure in university,
even if it's only 100 Euro every month,
it will really make a
significant difference
over the long-term
if you do this in a
good and consistent way.
Last but not least, my
insight number five,
and this is do things beyond
your nine-to-five job.
And this tip is especially important
for people maybe not working
in these super accelerated career tracks
that you have almost no
time of doing anything else
besides your job.
But the truth is that most
people live or work in a job
that goes from nine to
five, as it says, right?
So usually at 5:00 PM or at 6:00 PM,
you come home and then
you have the free evening
until the next day you
move back into your job.
And of course, it's great to
spend time with your family.
Of course, it's also great to watch TV,
to maybe watch Netflix.
And you're for sure just
up to every single one
to prioritize your time and
make these decisions for you.
But especially, if you find yourself
sitting in front of the TV
or sitting in front of the
computer every single evening,
not really doing the things
that will do the difference
for you in the longterm,
I would challenge yourself
whether you wouldn't find the time
to rather work on some side projects,
to work on a couple of ideas,
which they may be in the longterm
might create some additional
income for yourself
on top of your daily nine-to-five job.
Because one thing is for sure,
while it might feel great
to watch Netflix in the evening,
and I'm for sure guilty
of that regularly as well,
you could have invested that time
in some productive activities
that really pay you
in the longterm in the evening.
And for sure, I truly believe
that a significant portion
of where you will be
in five years from now,
in 10 years from now,
in 20 years from now,
will be determined how you
spend this additional time
in the evening.
Spending this time in a productive way
can make the difference in your life,
can really have a huge
impact on your life,
on your career,
that is probably not even
possible to overestimate.
So now I would love to hear
from you, does this resonate?
Does this makes sense?
What are your tips?
What are your insights that you collected
over the course of your life,
which maybe you would love to share
back to the Firm Learning community?
I would love to read some
of your comments as well,
and probably also read a
couple of things from you.
So please just write a comment
in the comment section about that.
As always if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to this
channel to stay up to date
on all my content.
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday.
If you want to see even more from me,
also follow me on Instagram,
and also recently started to
become more active on TikTok.
Links to these channels are included below
in the video description.
And I wanna end by saying a big thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning.
Thank you so much for your support.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Good weekend to all of you and bye-bye.